president biden's push to restore
america's relations with its allies
at a high-stakes summit in britain
yesterday he met with
british prime minister boris johnson who
called him a breath of fresh air
both men are in cornwall for the g7
summit
of the world's seven wealthiest
democracies which starts today
our nancy cordes is there as well nancy
the president has already had some
success
negotiating a more robust international
response to the pandemic what's on the
agenda today
well anthony today some of the world's
most powerful leaders are going to be
gathering in this tiny seaside town
to discuss ways to build back after
covid19 and president biden revealed
yesterday that they are set to announce
as a group today new measures to combat
the pandemic
it's a great pleasure to be here
president biden says he's looking for a
reset today
when he sits down with the other six g7
allies
who did not always see eye to eye with
his predecessor
everybody is absolutely thrilled to see
you the fence mending started yesterday
with a friendly roughly 90-minute
meeting with uk
prime minister boris johnson we covered
a huge range of
of subjects and it's it's wonderful to
to listen to the biden administration
and to joe biden
in a bit of fashion diplomacy first lady
dr jill biden donned a love
jacket drawing comparisons with former
first lady melania trump
who famously wore one that read i really
don't care
do you on a trip to meet migrant
children at a texas detention center
we're bringing love from america another
show of soft
power came when president biden
announced a plan to buy
half a billion doses of the pfizer
vaccine and
share them with low-income nations
around the world america
will be the arsenal of vaccines
in our fight against global 19.
just as america was the arsenal
democracy during world war ii
mr biden said the doses come with no
strings attached
a move to counter russia and china's
recent push
to use vaccines to gain influence white
house covid response coordinator jeff
zeins
spearheaded the purchase expected to
total 3.5 billion dollars
is this donation meant to challenge
other industrialized nations
to step up their giving as well
absolutely i think all the world's
democracies need to come together to
show
that the world's democracies can tackle
the biggest problem
and the biggest problem that we face is
covet 19.
all this talk about democracies and
alliances it's more than just
platitudes it's meant to send a message
to russia and china in particular
that the world's biggest democracies are
united again
and working together and that democracy
itself is still the most effective
form of government tony nancy cordes for
us in cornwall nancy thank you very much